okay that is really happy to introduce
our next amazing speaker terrific
I got to know how in 2400 and remember
that's when I interned in IBM not in the
crypto group that I was living in secure
hardware power remember me back then
well things since then and Taos group
has been renamed the algorithm
foundation right nothing really changed
under house leadership the group is
still cranking out the most amazing work
so it's really just to make that change
and how has worked on the foundations of
distributed computing and multi-party
computation so a lot of my own work
actually was inspired and built upon
without amazing research and I think
maybe the same for many of you in the
room
Tao has received many awards like she is
a Award for Excellence in mathematics
and she is an ATM fellow and the fellow
of the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences
she's an RIAA CR fellow she has been
named woman while fishing for innovation
by the Anita Park Institute and also and
Tao is a really powerful and influential
woman for example she has been named one
of the one of America's top 50 women
intact by far and she's also named one
of the tiny two most powerful women
engineers in the world by different
things either so now what this means
if you are lucky enough that's how
invites you to one of her parties are to
another amid the events you're not
allowed to say now really a lot of these
to help more junior women in theoretical
computing my furry six she founded the
the women in theory workshop so you are
allowed to say that you don't want to
come to the party if I had invited
that's fine but I do remember meeting
Elaine I don't know when the year was
but I think that Elaine is very
noticeable because she gets so excited
from work and from everything so it's
always a pleasure to interact with her
on any front so okay so I'm gonna talk
about so first of all I want to thank
both Elaine and Dahlia for inviting me
and for dolly for giving me advice about
what to talk about
but between time she told me and I
prepared to talk I forgot I hope that I
somehow it's related to what you said
I'm not sure okay we don't know each
other from yesterday regarding
instructions anyways okay so this is
work that I'm gonna talk in its joint
work with Christian who's here here with
who václav cheek
Jason rash and let's go with Chrissa and
[Music]
it's interesting this was work that was
done when all five of us were at IBM and
miraculously now only Chris's at IBM
which is something that nobody could
have believed in okay so um first I want
to describe what I want to do and I'll
start with the very picture pictorial
thing you mined bitcoins and you have a
wallet and the good thing is that you
mind them in 2011
so and you have 10,000 tokens so you
really have a lot of money okay and now
you want to keep this money from getting
lost I'm sure all of you read from time
to time this wallet was broken into this
money was lost and so on so our the
wallets protected they're protected by a
digital signature key because to spend
the money you sign with the key and the
question is where do you keep this key
how do you protect the key how do you
not lose the key
it's not just if somebody breaks into
your wallet and they can sign and take
your coins away from you actually even
just losing the key is an issue because
you yourself cannot sign in fact those
tokens will be lost to everyone but
you'll be the only one will be really
sad about it so these are all really
good questions and what is the answer
what do we do with these things so we
can try and think of various solutions
to address this thing you have to tell
me they're in the back if I yeah okay
okay I just have to see the slides I
don't want to keep turning backwards
okay it's some risk to make okay never
mind that's only power okay you know
what I'll put it in okay
one more second guys the talks gonna
resume okay there we go okay now I hope
I can see it a little better
okay now that does not look like what I
think should
okay so we can think of all kinds of
solutions to try and alleviate the
problem so for example if we don't want
our key to be stolen we can say we'll
use an air-gapped computer we'll go into
this room with our computer with our you
know that thing that shields the
interaction from the computer so nobody
can read read anything of the bits that
are going back and forth but this is not
really an accessible solution especially
if you want to be buying from your
wallet continuously and it's prone to
human error error and it has this
problem that there's a single point of
failure that key is still in one
location if someone wants to break into
that location the key is there okay so
another solution to alleviate one
problem which is the loss of your key is
you can duplicate the key you can put
one key in one computer and another key
in another computer but this now you've
increased the vulnerability of the key
because now an attacker can try either
to attack computer a were one kiss or
two attack computer B where the second
key is and you've really reduced it to
the weakest link of these two computers
which is not a great situation so here
is another attempt at a solution you
will say that now the location of your
house solution is in top three words
they decide suite random words for each
three-base yes I read about it yes yes
touching Samoa touching phrase to your
to your digital to your okay any you've
just transformed it from one key to
another key
it's not you have to it's not that
simple I mean those who has to be a key
that you have to sign with it has to be
part of a digital signature scheme so
yeah so how big is it going to be Ellie
at our age 10 letters max okay so let's
be realistic here about the key okay so
what you say is you transform the key
not to be a single key but you say when
I give a signature it really has to be
out I'll assign keys k1 k2 k3 and it
really should be a signature consisting
of signatures under each and every one
of these keys okay but this thing has so
so this really helps and you can take as
I said and you can put any two so here
I've attached let's say two and you say
that this is the signature so you've
improved on the vulnerability of the key
because now in order to forge a
signature on your behalf somebody has to
attack both location 1 and location 2
not or but and okay but these things now
make the signatures very long and also
makes the public key very long so we're
losing in storage and in computation
something which we don't want there are
some solutions with my linear maps that
maybe alleviate the issue of how the
signature is generated but the public
key still needs to be big and that's an
issue okay so what can we do to start
giving a solution to this problem that
will both give us availability and
security for the key we can take in this
key K and we can share it again I'm
giving an exact example with three sub
keys k1 k2 and k3
and in some magical way any two are
sufficient to create the key cake okay
and now we put them in three separate
locations as we did before but now the
question is these keys let's say if you
think about it in the most trivial way
let's say k1 plus k2 equals K okay so I
can't say I'm giving a signature under
k1 and under k2 these things have to
somehow be combined to generate the key
K and to generate the signature under
the key K so let's say we take k1 and k2
here's a trivial solution of how we do
it if we take k1 and k2
let's say location 1 sends to location
to location 2 sums k1 and k2 gets K and
signs but this is not a good solution
because it goes back to creating a
single point of failure right because
the minute that k1 is transferred here
even if since some secure manner
now both shares are here and again you
can attack only a single location so
this is not a good thing so we really
need to be able to sign using these the
key in its distributed form that is that
location 1 will create something and
location 2 will create something
independently and then we will
reconstruct these things back in order
to generate the full signature under the
key K
so this is where threshold crypto came
into existence and in fact threshold
crypto is a subset of the area of
multi-party computations and in
multi-party computations due to results
from the 80s including share fees we
know that we can compute any function
and this is basically any function where
the input is distributed each party P I
holds an input X I we can compute any
function f of X 1 up to xn in a way that
preserves the privacy of the inputs and
this is exactly what we had here we had
k1 as an input k2 as an input and we can
compute any function specifically the
signature under key so we know that we
have these theoretical results but what
threshold crypto came and said is that
we want to be able to do these
multi-party computations but in an
efficient way
there is something in digital signatures
which are computing exponents which are
not very natural in the multi-party
computation setting the multi-party
computation setting is based on circuits
and that and those take a long time to
compute so we want to offer some
efficiency for computing these functions
signatures encryption and so on so we
will get all the improved secrecy and
availability that we get from this
distribution but also we will offer
efficiency and computation of the
functions so this is sort of the goal of
distributed cryptography to do the
operations that we already know how to
do but in an efficient manner let's just
give a very quick example of what can
happen with that k1 and k2 so let's
assume that a signature and I'm highly
simplifying is G to the K so party 1 and
G and it's mod p let's say it's it's not
really a signature but and G and P are
known to
everyone p1 will give us G to the K 1 P
2 will give us G to the K 2 and then
they'll simply multiply this this things
can be made public their security is
equivalent to the security of seeing the
signature and then you just get G to the
K 1 which is exactly G to the K okay so
I showed you how very simply we can
create a threshold computation for
computing an exponent which is highly
efficient each one of the party
basically just does a local
exponentiation everybody publishes the
information and you multiply the two
parts so there has been recently renewed
interest in this area the area of
threshold crypto was alive and kicking
in starting from the mid 90s or maybe a
little bit early 90s and sort of ran its
course into the 2000s with results for
everything for signatures RSA DSS can
you bring me some water
thank you for RSA DFS key generation and
so on for all the systems that we knew
but now there is interest in these
results again partially driven by really
blockchain technology but also for other
reasons because these techniques really
offer security four very important keys
and offer very interesting
functionalities and in fact NIST is also
now announced that it's going to be
standardizing techniques for threshold
which is very important because this
really does great job at these things
and we of course use mostly their
standards for many things
it's a good question thank you I do
think that partially it is the
blockchain but I have to say that some
time ago there was some weird report by
Congress that said that multi-party
threshold and proactive security are
exactly the things that are needed in
order to ensure security in the Internet
I can send you a copy but so I don't
know how it relates but there are people
there in fact NIST is populated by a lot
of great cryptographers and I think that
they are aware of these things they grew
on these notions they studied while the
time that it was happening but I do
think that the cryptocurrency are a push
for that because it's needed for these
things now they have time the new topics
out you know some takes time for people
to get senior
okay okay so let me give you another
motivating example if your wallet was
not of them enough of a motivating
example you can be in a permission block
chain okay this is not a decentralized
complete everybody participates but in
this blockchain
there's an encrypted database and the
owners of the database want to provide
answers to questions about membership in
the database and various other questions
so but they they want to do it in such a
way that they compute these things in an
encrypted manner and only once that that
you have the encrypted encrypted
solution they want to decrypt only that
specific item and not give a full
decryption on the database so what is
done is that it's encrypted under a key
that none of them know they somehow
share it in this way that I had told you
before and then they run the
computations and then they distributive
lis decrypt this thing I had showed you
encryption sort of creating an
exponentiation but we also know to do
the reverse operations okay so what kind
of solutions did we have in the 90s and
the 2000s you it you could do the
computation homomorphic lee that would
definitely be efficient in some method
and you keep the homomorphic key
distributed
excuse me yes maybe you can do some some
computation under the key I don't know
it doesn't neccessarily okay so that was
a bit of a misuse I could have maybe
done other things maybe it's yes yes
MIDI encryption it could be some
computation but basically you arrive at
the result at the end encrypted in some
form and then you decrypt it it's not in
the sense of a multi-party computation
okay may you mean like delegated
computations or right right right right
so for example we have another result
that you do operations on genomic data
thumbs hold by the hospital some is hold
by the doctor and then at the end the
answer is delivered only to the doctor
but this is not under encryption this is
sort of a right okay
okay so as I said before we had
solutions for all these things for all
the signature schemes encryption schemes
that existed at the time of course later
when fully homomorphic came about then
people also did threshold schemes for
fully homomorphic and so on
but how did we design our protocols we
assumed broadcast and that the parties
were all synchronous as a Christian said
in his talk cryptographers don't care so
we simply you know it was a nice
assumption and we just moved with it and
it was of course easier to design
protocols under these assumptions but
not only easier in the technical sense
and also allowed us to achieve very nice
results and sort of to reach the lower
bounds if we're talking about end
parties participating in these
computations we could show that we could
tolerate up to half of the parties being
faulty which is optimal you cannot do
any better than that
so what happens when theory meets
reality we always know that maybe not
the best so first of all turns out that
there's no broadcast that you don't have
things that you send and everybody hears
it magically okay so gone and then turns
out that synchronicity is another bit of
a complicated assumption that we can't
really think that this would be the case
either God okay so now what do we do and
it's what's interesting about both these
things is I had said that we managed to
reach optimal solutions where the number
of faulty parties was could withstand up
to a half faulty parties but maybe it
depended only on more only on one of
these requirements but no turns out that
any one of these that we would give up
we would be stuck with going down to a
resilience of only a third we cannot
sustain a half anymore because the
broadcast requires a third and in fact
the synchronicity moving to an
asynchronous model also requires us to
go up to a third of the party being
faulty
so do we care maybe yes because there is
a lower bound that you can tolerate at
most a third right so the signatures but
this would bring you up to t plus one
rounds we're taught we want to do
constant expected okay so for the
constant expected you still need with us
right the Cohen Katz thing mmm okay
you're right maybe in that case I
shouldn't say that it's both maybe
really you're right the corn cuts that's
gonna have okay so um maybe it's okay
that we can tolerate only a third maybe
it's not that bad but it makes some
cases I'm totally impossible and in some
cases it reduces our resilience to a
point that we really don't want to be in
that case so first of all you cannot
have a protocol with three parties and
three parties is a very common number
people really want to have protocols for
three servers it somehow I don't know
why but it's a realistic number that
people say okay we'll do three parties
okay so no three parties but also in the
case of five for example think about it
if you are in the case of five you can
tolerate to faulty parties if you're in
the case of a half but you have to go
down to only one if you're tolerating a
third so
that's not optimal it really creates a
big restriction now if you have five
parties
you really have to ensure that four are
correct all the time and not broken into
and surprisingly even in big numbers it
matters for running a system with a
hundred servers trying to reach to do
some computation this goes down from 50
to 33 so in every setting this
difference of a third of going from a
half to a third matters it's not a good
situation okay so can we bridge that gap
so here we're in the asynchronous place
we have a third and here we have the
synchronous bound which is a half and
the question is can we somehow
go down so again to that point this
thing of the lower bound because we do
is from digital signatures it this is
really not the case
but the asynchronous network definitely
seems to apply that we need to t plus
one okay so what we want to propose is
the is the following it's been mentioned
in many of the talks
what's our assumption what are we saying
about these processors do they about
their behavior what is their Byzantine
faults how often do they happen and so
on and the the reality in life is that
we build systems trying to tolerate a
big number of faults but in fact these
faults don't happen that often in
today's system if it's a system that
you're trying to secure and maintain in
positive in good standing most of the
time the servers are up and not broken
into so in that setting can we sort of
move and say
we will build our protocol and we will
try to introduce and here's to your
request from the talk that we save DNS
and PNL I didn't know you said f NS and
F for now but I have TNS and you know I
I cited to change when you said it but I
decided against it so the question
really is can we do something can we say
we'll leave this all-encompassing number
of total faults and we'll split the
things in two directions and we'll say
we'll have these two parameters the D
for security and the t4 liveness and we
will go between these two things
what will the t for security mean the
taesik for security will mean that if
you really go beyond that number of
faults you're really gonna be in trouble
because then you're gonna lose for
example the key
so that's major but we're willing to
sacrifice something in liveness we're
gonna say we may lose liveness before
the case of the third but as long as few
faults happen we will have both liveness
and security we will maintain the
secrecy of our key and still
continuously run the system because in
most cases we will not lose liveness
because we'll have much fewer faults and
this is where we were previously which
is the third and what we're saying is
we're gonna go and we're gonna move
we're gonna lose one in liveness but
we're gonna gain two in our in the
security and so we're gonna go all the
way up to the point that we're saying
we'll have security
even if up to 1/2 our corrupted will not
lose the data before that but we can go
up to here but we will lose liveness a
bit earlier at 1/4 rather than at a
third ok
what was the question okay if it's the
imagery than I didn't do it okay okay
that's very interesting and I think that
we can prove a lower bound okay so you
understand why we stopped at a half well
maybe you don't but the point is we're
doing all kinds of things of secret
sharing so we can never go beyond the
half because we don't have schemes that
enable us to both reconstruct and keep
secret so we're stuck here and this
somehow drove the quarter in our results
maybe maybe we can do something are they
less than equal as long as you have less
than app yeah I'm all the time cheat
with her you know at the bottom for a
four you can have only one wrong okay
you cannot have two yes yes less than or
equal but okay it depends if the numbers
odd or even okay so yes all these I
always fudge a little bit when I said
less then at most and so on but the idea
is you can never not go beyond 1/2 okay
so as I said this is a very viable
approach because we we're really
optimizing sort of for the case where
really there gonna be few faults and
because of that we will be able to
compute most of the time the system will
be running okay so this is just a graph
depicting it and as I said before
there's a two to one trade-off between
the secrecy and the liveness okay so now
we wanted to design these protocols
under these new assumptions that we
don't have the synchronicity nor the
broadcast so we want to substitute the
broadcast with a BFD protocol and now
the question is what do we do how do we
design this protocol to achieve these
property
this idea of having to perish holes
computing eventually synchronous okay
it's also appeared in crypto as well
this is not new okay okay no no no no no
it's not however in our case in the
asynchronous setting for threshold these
solutions did not exist so this is if I
had made the appearance that we invented
two thresholds of no okay what do you
mean two hours ago it was mentioned by
one of the people in okay so so what do
we want from our so we call everything
is tunable and what we mean by junuh
ball is that you can make assumptions
about your system of where do you think
how many faults you would have how many
attacks you want to tolerate and so on
and then you sort of fix your point in
that range between these things but of
course once you've fixed it for example
if you went for half the liveness is a
force it's calculated by a function that
correlates these two numbers okay so
what do we have what does the BFG
provide us it says in fact it's very
interesting there were a lot of talks
that mentioned it but nobody said what
it was but I'll say it quickly because
I'm assuming really this everybody knows
but as long as most the third of the
parties are faulty and the parties start
with message and I the protocol will
terminate if an honest party terminates
and outputs em all honest parties will
output them and I didn't say anything
about the meaning of the BA that is that
they all start with the same message it
should be that message that's output it
and if the security property is violated
I mean if we go beyond the threshold
there's really no assurance what happens
in this BFD protocol we really don't
know
what will happen in this design but it's
amazingly we'll still managed to use
this vft despite the fact that bad
things actually bad things can happen
but will overcome okay so as we said we
have our two parameters the security
that's less than 1/2 and the liveness
that's less than 1/4
I took a specific example and again you
start with MI and what you want to say
is that if less than 1/4 of the parties
will be eventually in the protocol
actually corrupted you will have both
liveness and correctness
however if more than 1/4 is corrupted
but still less than 1/2 you'll have
correctness in the sense that if one
honest party outputs in then all the
other parties will output in and this
seems a little bit amazing because in
fact it could be the case that we are
beyond the third that the BFT requires
ok and again here this thing that I
failed to mention in the previous time
ok so how will this go we have the BFT
protocol is going to be running and here
we see the view in for a single party
and they've run a few B if these are the
protocol is going and they've they're
continuously expanding this view of what
are the messages so they've gotten up to
m6 and I haven't told you but also the
tunable BFT is up to Capital m 6 ok now
and 7 comes along and now what will we
add on top of this protocol and this
follows along with the lines of the
protocol that Alain and Rafael have in
Thunder Allah it's very similar and but
it's tailored to our situation but
basically the same idea
now this party will wait to see enough
signatures ok
and the minute that it sees enough
signatures
and how much is enough it's m- the
liveness threshold okay so in the case
that was a fourth they have to see three
quarters of n signatures on this value
in that case it adds it to em say it
adds it to the tunable BFT it adds it is
m7 these two are equal and it
distributes these signatures
so what are we guaranteed that if an
honest party had enough signatures saw
enough valid signatures and now it
propagates it to everyone else all the
other honest parties will add m7 to
their tunable bf theory that they're
extending okay so let's think about it
what happened so clearly if there were
left less than 1/4 of the faults the
underlying bft works everybody agrees
all the good guys agree on m7 they all
sign it we have enough signatures okay
what happens in the case when the
underlying BST failed and in fact one
honest party has m7 prime m7 and another
one has m7 Prime in that case it could
go either way it could be that enough
party saw this thing and there were
enough signatures and then everybody
will add it just because they saw the
signatures not because they agreed in
the Byzantine Agreement protocol in the
underlying bft but on top of that they
managed to see the same thing and they
added it or it never comes to that point
there aren't enough signatures and
liveness is lost in the protocol hopes
it doesn't halt it hangs okay so yes I'm
assuming synchrony no
I'm not assuming that they're
synchronous this is the whole point the
BFD is not synchronous the underlying
thing it's just running and at this
point I'm they just sit there and they
collect the signatures they arrive
whenever they arrive if they don't
arrive liveness is lost okay
but eventually yes what happened to I'll
go back to it if you have more than a
third faults one honest this is let's
say the view of p1 he sees m7 and p2 is
also on this sees m7 Prime okay now
either there are enough good signatures
3/4 and generated in the system and then
some honest guy seizes and he propagates
the signatures to all the rest the
minute that he sees enough signatures he
sends them all out so now even p2 who
finished with m7 prime is gonna adopt
them 7 and insert it into the thing
however if not enough signatures come
along
we lost liveness which is exactly the
case because we said more than 1/3 which
means that it's more than 1/4 and I
promised only correctness I didn't
promise liveness ok 7 prior has to
change its opinion right
I can't hear yes they do change they
still haven't I'm only I'm claiming
correctness for this array ok this array
might have something else ok but the
minute that they adopt the mm7 in the
BFT they can also copy it in here and
they continue ok but yes that good party
who finished the BFT with a different
value does change its mind changes its
mind ok it sees overwhelming proof for
another value but that's why we're so
far away from the 3
where were 3/4 he sees 3/4 signatures
which means that the intersection of the
good of the goods you can't have another
value that would have 3/4 signatures
because you have too much you don't have
enough honest parties to sign this thing
so that's exactly it sort of separates
you apart which is really the important
point yes then you have another quarter
that are sending you something but
they're actually sending different
messages to yes ok excellent so so this
is exactly what I was trying to say a
second ago um
so you're saying a quarter are being
delayed by the adversary you cannot say
that they two are corrupt ok a quarter
are being delayed a quarter are sending
varying messages and now we have the
good parties ok so now the question is
what's the situation with the good
parties did they all find the same value
I'm asking you you that's your setting
ok so they all find the same good value
em7 ok now if the bad parties are
sending signatures to some for em7 and
some for m7 prime there is gonna be a
good party that's gonna see everything
if they all send then he's gonna see 3/4
and he's gonna adopt that value and it's
gonna move forward if the bad party
split and they send mix then you won't
get the 3/4 3/4 and for the sleeping
ones eventually when they wake up
because it's not indefinitely that they
sleep they will also adopt m7 if an
honest person adopted it because why
because there were three quarters
signatures here ok ok ok
so yes I'm gonna read you soon a text
from one of my co-workers from hygge
who's listening all day online and he
said to me texted me just before the
time don't make people ask questions
okay here you go
if it looks if it's not thing is a
deadly said but like they replied
different signatures yes the good guys
okay so there are two different cases it
slightly depends on the behavior of the
adversary if for example the adversary
since - he gets Elly to sign 0 & 1 then
you can identify that Elias faulty you
notify the administrator out-of-band and
the server is rebooted and so on but
there could be a situation where it
hangs I don't want to see because he
could be doing he could just be passive
passively attacking the system so all
these solutions really require to be
fixed from outside we cannot internally
fix it that would completely contradict
there any lower any lower bounds that we
have so definitely we're talking about
real systems this is not theoretical and
we would need mechanisms to enforce to
reboot hopefully we can only reboot le
but sometimes we would need to reboot
the whole system because we won't be
able to identify the faults so this is
definitely a part of our solution which
is outside the cryptographic protocol
itself well you have to get a signature
from him both for 0 and 1 when you
deliver I'll do the rebooting ok and
he's not amused
ok ok
so as I said we I talked with that and
as you asked the option of fault
detection it could be the case that we
would have fault detection but there are
cases where we cannot and then we would
need to do something yes it's gonna be
some local clock now I don't have to be
synchronized with others but I can say
listen I've been waiting an hour
you know these things should be tick
think I'm you know something's wrong
okay
what we can say it okay so what we
actually do in our paper is on top of
this tunable BFT we construct tunable
everything distributed key generation
signatures decryption proactive a notion
that I didn't discuss prfs and many more
okay so let's try and talk a little bit
about the next primitive which is
important which is distributed key
generation because what do we want in
many cases we want the encryption scheme
to be such that nobody knows the secret
key that is encrypting things that it
would have also been generated in a way
that nobody holds the information so
this for everybody was a little bit
familiar with multi-party computations
this always starts from verifiable
secret sharing or secret sharing as the
basis and the idea is that there's a
party and it has an input and it sort of
can distribute it amongst the set of
parties so that any subset of T can
reconstruct the secret but any subset of
less than T cannot reconstruct the
secret okay I had shown you before in
some sense the secret sharing when I
said X 1 X 2 X 3 and I said any tool can
reconstruct k and with one you cannot
okay so we have this technique for
shamil secret sharing I'll show it in
more detail later but what happens in
this synchronous setting is that
you're not guarantee exactly dahlias
thing right these parties are sitting
there they're delayed because of the
adversary they're really not malicious
but we're just sitting there and waiting
and it's always this tension in the
asynchronous model that you don't know
if you're waiting for someone because
they're late or you don't know if you're
waiting for them because they're bad so
we're sort of stuck in this case but
what's important in this secret sharing
scheme is we always need to be assured
that each party has a part of the key
okay so if we have three parties k1 k2
k3 they each have to know this part it
cannot be that only p1 and p2 got their
pieces and and p3 did not so we need
this extra thing but it's complicated in
this asynchronous setting because we
don't know what to do these people
haven't told us that they have their
piece but we need to move on because
maybe they're never telling us and we
don't want that delay parties were maybe
malicious to create sort of a denial of
service attack okay so as I said we need
that all parties need their shares and
why it's exactly what I explained we
might be stuck later if we're missing
some of the shares we're gonna have a
problem so Stadler introduced a
mechanism called publicly verifiable
secret sharing and what this means is
that
when you do the sharing you can verify
the share the shares of the parties are
given out under some scheme that we know
that the receiving party can extract the
secret out of it and we verify on some
public information that the sharing is
proper that these shares really create
something however
Stadler didn't use encryption
he used some forms of commitments and
from that the secrets were not easily
extractable so the question was whether
we can do something that will guarantee
that we can extract the secrets easily
and big secrets when it's commitment you
can only do small secrets but we
actually need keys with a lot of entropy
so he did a commitment let's say that
the share is put in g2 the ki it's a
stupid example okay and then let's say
it's ten digits so then a bit so he
checks all the 10 numbers and he
extracts it I'm giving a stupid example
but something like that but you can't
you know in Hebrew say we say you can't
build a nation on that you need more
than that ok so we start we assume that
there's a PKI and each party has a
public key PKI
and the secret is shared and this is the
shamil secret sharing scheme via
polynomial f of X whose is defined by
random numbers 8 to the P X to the T
where a 0 is the secret that you're
sharing and you create shares for each
party by computing F at I this is the
share of party P I and you can see very
easily that any set of T plus 1 parties
can interpolate the polynomial and thus
derive its constant term and for any
subset of less than T plus 1 even T you
still have any value could
we do okay okay
so it's true but I'm I said that I'm
gonna be increasing the security so now
in order to get these shares I'm gonna
be encrypting the shares under these
public keys I need to break into more
computers okay because let's say let's
use this exact example with t + 1 in
order and let's say that this is the
public key the important key that I was
trying to protect okay now I have a PKI
or in five loke in a hundred locations I
don't know let's say T is 50 101 and now
I am in order to get this value I need
to break 50 keys okay that's it it was
before I did the PKI that it was true
okay your complaint it's not now that I
introduced the PKI this you should have
asked before that's what I'm saying okay
so it was already the problem but that's
what I said now you have to break into
more computers I increase the security
by distributing the information okay so
now I'm I'm gonna prove so encrypt every
share under the public key of P I and
now I'm going to prove in zero-knowledge
that all these encryptions the
underlying information of in them define
a polynomial of degree T okay so now
what happens with all those slow guys
usually in secret sharing what you do is
after the secret is shared everybody
says I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay I have my share but here
I'm waiting and I can't hear but now I
verified for everybody that they're
gonna have their share I know that the
sleeping people let's say p1 p2 and p3
that this is encrypted under their key
they're gonna be able to decrypt it I
verified that it's good and now I can
move forward even without hearing from
everyone and I know that once they wake
up they will be able to have access to
their share and B and now I can move
forward okay and as I said this is an
interesting feature that oh sorry
there's a further interesting feature
before I said if that attacker attacks
more than a quarter we may lose liveness
okay
but the issue there's a very important
issue in our threshold schemes it's okay
for the Byzantine Agreement but in our
threshold schemes
once we've generated a key then it's an
important key we can't say okay now the
adversary can cause us to lose liveness
this is not okay in some settings so
really what we want to ensure that after
a certain point if we past that point
then and the adversary let it go through
it persisted and gave us liveness up to
that point now even if he goes beyond
the liveness bound we will still be able
to continue so from a certain point we
move our liveness to a higher point but
we have to cross that specific point and
here in this secret sharing scheme in
this publicly verifiable secret sharing
scheme this is the case the minute that
the sharing is complete I didn't
describe the final step when they agree
that the sharing is complete but it
wants it to determine that the sharing
is complete now even if the
versary goes beyond our lightness bound
we will still be able to operate okay so
now on top of this thing on top of the
publicly verifiable secret sharing we
build one of them portent tools as I
said the distributed key generation
which means that people generate the key
so that nobody knows it and it's a key
for a distributed for a digital
signature scheme or an encryption scheme
and as I said here it's really where
it's important that we need this
property that after a certain point that
versary cannot make us lose liveness
and this happens once we finish the key
generation then the key will never be
lost okay okay and now I want to say
that this design that we have is AI also
been implemented there is a URL where
this thing exists and it's open-source
MIT license and we support a various set
of operations
OPR FS RSA blind signing and decryption
and so on and it really is builds on
this BFP layer and we use BFT smart
doesn't specific implementation we
create our tunable layer with our
messages as I described to you and on
top of that we have our shareholders and
all the functionalities that we provide
and that is it thank you
I have a question how can you modify
this game to do for that solution in
case one of the parties are boys say
again which one okay so some cases yes
but some cases no we don't necessarily
we're not necessarily able to do that
and so maybe you have some mechanism
that you say if you haven't heard from a
party in a long time then you notify the
admin that you're not receiving their
messages of course I said there are
behaviors which are easily detectable to
conflicting signatures you know exactly
what the protocol is and if in fact some
party creates two that are different you
send it to the admin and they can verify
that in fact something is going wrong in
the system they're not necessarily
thinking of making the context of the
canonical further
félicité say yes
so so I want to say something they deal
with signature generation okay the keys
already been generated and now they're
signing so in fact when you're signing
some of the signature schemes have a
mechanism to verify or you can provide a
zero knowledge proof that you've created
your partial signature correctly so if
you don't then you can have sort of at
the station to the fact that somebody
was malicious you can incorporate that
into the protocol so then then you have
people who can either talk but then they
have to prove that they're doing things
properly or they're silent but then we
go to the silent cases the difficult
case all the time people think you know
it's somebody being malicious that's a
problem but in fact no it's being silent
that's worse because you can't this
thing
maybe you could just leave your previous
slide up in your answer because I don't
understand how the two parts fit
together like what is the replicated
okay this is exactly what I had
described before this was this is the
BFG layer which is creating locally for
each party their output from the BFT and
then they move it into the he called it
the tunable certification layer okay but
that's what I had on top with the
capital ends okay it's just this was
done by the person who did the
implementation and I draw my own slide I
have to tell you after seeing Morris's
slides in the previous talk I almost
fainted those are exactly the type of
slides I always wanna make but never do
so yes to reproduce so basically do not
changing the threshold in the red layer
right this is yes right right and things
yes yes and in fact things can go
terribly wrong in the red layer terribly
they don't cascade up there they're
blocked
splitting the key let's say to two
computers is breaking to two computers
chain workshop no but have an answer to
the question that I'm anticipating yes
let ask for these two computers to start
to do something on my behalf I have two
loci in one I have to login in in
another which means the theft to I don't
know another way to login that exciting
remember remembering passwords so you
say okay there is a password for this
one there is a password for this one so
and you have room only for 10 characters
we already decided okay so your our
example okay so it's an excellent
question and in fact it really is an
issue what you're saying how do more
than that how do I give instructions to
these these are not necessarily my
computers maybe I stored them in the
cloud how do I give instructions for
these people to do and what password I
do luckily there is a paper for that so
who go has a paper with the stash and I
think there are more authors on the
paper and they deal exactly with that
question
so yes ok it's not your gonna ask
something else but I had an answer to
this one too yes
but silence participants then you're
stealing or my teens like it a quarter
no you have to go
which one the red one no the red one is
a regular BFT it'll lose only at a third
if this one fails only when there is a
third but I will lose I will lose I will
lose liveness on top of it okay so okay
okay you're gonna wait for three
quarters yes in the case half a quarter
just so we know we're talking about
educator yes yes conference where when
you talked about it crypto I had it to
do to look because I think your schemes
can enhance this to get better results
already willing to sacrifice right right
right I completely forgot yes but I was
thinking about that exactly when you
were talking at crypto yes
good okay it remind me for a short time
again yes then 50 smart must be must
collect more than must collect 3 3/4 of
the signatures right 50 smart
no it's it were it's a regular BFT smart
we didn't modify it we built something
on top of it that now starts collecting
the minute that a party finishes the red
layer and if something was inputted to
here they sign it and then it goes up to
the top level BFT smart is not modified
it's exactly the same
give it stuff sorry this is blowing my
mind okay that's what I want to hear at
the end of my talk it's blowing my mind
okay he knows how to be a smart player
yeah deliver different decisions on a
particular slot yes yes but you know
that at that case with the half a
quarter I already do not guarantee
anything at the top layer because you
said a third the third is more than a
fourth line aliveness exactly they want
to honest parties will not put a
different m capital seven and then M
prime capital seven broad and blue is
garbage
okay thank you very much and that we're
gonna end this
[Applause]